that's the thing that killed my man IMAX  I'd be like the best one here with all  the explosions and the running and the  Predators just like biting people's  heads off he's a big badass honestly and  the sound and the way that he moves you  have to experience the magnitude of this  film and that character within the film  and an IMAX you have to yeah there's so  much to experience yeah also I think  he's so big that he doesn't fit in  normal things it's not a predator that's  a sports hunter well we took a vote  predators cooler right I mean I wouldn't  wanna be watching this me on a laptop  don't do that to us so you actually have  to watch it remembers the predator  experienced it in IMAX  you